memory and file size okay what would you
- um think about today's conversion how
to move between different file size
units so I want to make a bit of a
comparison here if I said to you one
liter okay so I'm now thinking about
capacity right what lead on is a
thousand what it's elements which we
would just say mils official now from
those excuse me what lead up if I had
say a thousand liters what would I call
that is it a good night you when you
have trouble remembering something the
way that I do things I always go back to
something just easy to remember so for
example if you say something is like
five kilograms cramps um who would write
that with it who would rather with the
capital okay okay all right now I can't
all just put the bow in it just let me
make sure you really clean that's a
thousand liters that's a cute okay if I
said a thousand kill it is but with that
big it's a big it's a big a little wrong
the wrong unit of measurement that's a
camera
one big Elena and this one's easier to
know it's a capital wiser to capital
it's big whereas this one is so I could
keep going but this is enough to
illustrate the point right as we as we
go up levels of Iran as we got levels
went multiplied by a thousand
and that's because the metric system is
based on the number 10 now what is the
metric system based on the number 10
okay so now counting system right our
counting system is what we call decimal
right because we have well there are 10
digits in our in our decimal system
right 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 & 8 9 ok there are
10 digits and the reason why there are
10 digits in our number system is
because there are 10 digits on our hands
like that's what digit means means
figure they called digits thank you if
you go look up the words Egypt it means
finger time so they would be your
decimal decimal base 10 okay because
there are 10 digits but when we have a
look at memory and file size on
computers everything is slightly
different now what I'm gonna do is two
things number one I'm just gonna show
you how it's different and in some
senses that's like the most important
thing doing it out today because that's
the thing you're gonna have to use ok
but because I'm always obsessed with
these things I also want to tell you a
little bit of why now if you're not that
interested in Y then that's okay you can
just take the how so this is like what
is this this is a capacity okay this is
how things work with capacity I'm gonna
show you the way they work with file
sizes it's kind of remarkably similar
but just a little bit different and if
if that's enough for you then come and
I'll redo let you get on with the
exercise I think it's well I've actually
written it down so where you can get
start on answering the questions okay
but for the rest of you who aren't
interested in curious like me I'll give
you a little bit of backstory as to one
so same kind of comparison here but it
starts off a little bit different rather
than saying liters and mils the smallest
units that are worth looking at when it
comes to file size are bits and bytes
so one but okay just like a leader is
kind of like a very basic unit one byte
is eight bits now again I'm not gonna
talk about what that means just yet
until I get something the why and if
you're curious yet but that's all you
need for the definition okay and then as
you get bigger and bigger units it does
something like this full burst if you
want to think about bytes and humans
okay now just how you look at this
comparison what do you think what would
be a sort of expected number to think
about how many bytes will be a kilobyte
doesn't 24 okay so a thousand would be a
common sense don't want to choose
because that's what kilo means but in
fact it's not it's a thousand and 24
it's almost a thousand but not quite so
that's one kilobyte okay I'll get to
those a bit later okay we're talking
about kilobytes
okay so I'll get so won't get to all of
the color ones so kilobyte that's KB if
I were to go up the next step again
instead of going up a thousand I'm gonna
go up this weird almost a thousand nine
if I have a thousand and twenty four
kilobytes
that's next step up it's a think about
it
I'll go 200 steps for you additional
steps okay in five a thousand and twenty
four megabytes so this is the MB you
said yeah right yeah then we call that
one gigabyte and only because we've been
monitoring the future proof things just
a little bit if I go one more step up
which is not that common these days but
it's just get going if you've got a
thousand and twenty four gigabytes which
is at the moment at least that's a heck
of a lot of gue writes is they don't
know we call that it's a terabyte okay
so nowadays you can't actually buy a one
or two terabyte hard drive for like a
reasonable amount of money yeah so which
is just crazy too because back in the
day like you know when people actually
own cameras that were just their phones
I bought a 128 big apply it like a
little memory card and it cost me like
like all my life savings isn't you 10
students anyway
I don't know if that says more about how
expensive that wasn't how poor I wasn't
you Tech students so have a look at this
if you want to know about how to convert
between different file sizes and I'll
get to the bits in kilobits a second
sooner we get to downloading a bit later
on and this is it this is it
now maybe you're like oh man that is
hard to remember the designers of the
general course also font size and so
that's why I want your formula - e if
you have a look if you have a look at
the arm the small page the second small
page you'll see it right down at the
bottom of the world on this page one two
third color okay now you'll also notice
a couple of other things there so you
can see everything that I've told you
but also you can see there's has been in
the middle where it's got the number of
bytes so there are really high numbers
of powers and they're all base to rather
than attack okay so I'm going to explain
that in a second but for now that's kind
of it let me give you a quick example of
how this works once we've done that I
will then dig into the and I'll show you
what questions you can go on with but
after that I'm going to do a little bit
for about five minutes into why I'm
gonna it's like
it's so close but not like I they just
try to big things on Tralee hot so
explain sorry sir well in about ten
minutes okay so a quick one quick one as
an example if I said to you how many
bytes in well let's say a four point
seven gigabytes a you might say well
that's been a funny number to choose
does they not know why I've chosen all
point seven point four point seven
gigabytes is exactly the amount of data
you can store on a DVD okay so you know
like a DVD that you put inside a drive
it's a I could explain that too if you
like but I'll get to that okay so all
this is is just a conversion problem
just like one of these is or just like
one of these right so how many bytes I'm
gonna go four point seven now in order
to best use that for exactly that be
trying to trip over myself right I'm
gonna convert one step at a time as
you'll see in a minute you can convert
as many steps as you like all at once
well you sort of just appreciate error
in just like if you had multiple steps
all in your head okay
so the first thing I'm going to do is
I'm going to climb down from Giga bytes
to the next step which is Giga bytes
right careful
well this is exactly why right so it's
easy if you like if you're just doing it
in your head to piece count the number
of steps that you're translating so when
you've got all this here in front of you
on your front of the data sheet you can
make sure you do one step at a time
so I'm going to include the unit's each
time I'm gonna go four point seven
gigabytes equals four point seven times
well by definition every gigabyte is
1024 megabytes
okay so 1024 megabytes okay I could go
ahead and work that in my calculator but
I don't even what megabytes I've got to
go another step from megabytes
tequila bytes and then I'm gonna have to
go to another one - do you see what's
going looking so I'm going to go four
point seven times a thousand 24 that
numbers there
x 1024 kilobytes so I've climbed a step
and then I'm gonna go one more time and
that should get me two bytes do you
agree
I've gone from gigabytes to megabytes to
kill lines to bots
okay now I could write 1024 one more
time but I'm kind of getting sick of
this
so instead I'm gonna write 1024 I've got
one two and I'm about to write 1/3 1/3
okay so now I've got bytes are you ok
with that
uh-huh so this is the whole point of
weird century notation because the same
idea I haven't explained yet why this is
tens and the ones on your formula - er
tuesd but this is basically I probably
actually would have written
go ahead and go find out okay um okay
does someone have a number for me
it requires yeah yeah it's gonna be good
right five seven three okay but yeah of
course it's alright now so yes this is
an extremely large number which is why
we use bigger units so we don't have to
keep on saying how many millions of
billions of bytes up you go up okay